So some identities
are those philosophies would say
determined it simple determinable,
so somewhere like race,
uh,
in principle,
you know,
the racial system is laid out so that
you have to be of either a mixed race or
one of the races and you can't be,
as it were,
black and an Asian at the same time.
You can be mixed race,
but you can't be straightforwardly Asian
and straightforward,
be black at the same time.
Uh,
so in that sense that mutual exclusivity
is built into the structure of some
kinds of identity,
but there's nothing in general about
identities that excludes the overlap of
different forms of identity,
of gender and race and sexual
orientation,
religion and nationality in class or in
a single person that indeed most people
have all of these things.
Um,
why?
Well,
what's a sensible thought about how to
deal with them?
Well,
first of all,
and this relates to what the proper
answer to the question,
and,
uh,
what's your identity is usually in a
context,
it's pretty clear which aspects of your
identity,
other ones that are relevant.
If I'm at a meeting of the American
Philosophical Association,
um,
my,
my identity as a philosopher is kind of
important,
but if I go to a meeting,
uh,
of,
you know,
a church group,
it probably isn't.
And so I know,
uh,
I know without thinking about it,
often what the relevance is of different
dimensions of my identity.
So when people get into trouble with us
is because they think that one dimension
of identity makes a demand on them
that's inconsistent with the demand made
by some other dimension of their ideas.
I think there are sort of two
helpful guiding thoughts.
One is,
um,
morality is helpful here.
That is to say there are general
obligations.
We have two other people independent of
their identities and our identities.
We better make sure that we discharged
those.
First of all.
So if you find yourself being pulled
into dementia directions by your
identities,
if you find yourself being pulled in one
direction,
say as a Serb and in the other direction
as a Christian,
it might be helpful to remember that
you're a human being and that you have
obligations to other people,
uh,
that are not connected with whether
you're being with your Serb or
Christian.
So I,
that's one thing.
Morality helps morality,
which,
which defines what we owed to everybody,
irrespective of their identities.
At the second thing is that sometimes we
do have to make choices.
That's part of what it is to make human
life.
It's the,
it's the way in the balance.
Am I going to go here with my religious
identity or am I going to go here with
my racial identity in this particular
context?
Or am I going to try and find some way
here?
The two unthought of to bring them
together without that strong tension and
people are doing this all the time.
It can sound very difficult in theory,
but I know my model for this really was
my father.
My father wasn't a santee and a and a
patriot of the Santee,
a Ghanaian and a patriot of Ghana.
Uh,
he wrote an autobiography called the
autobiography of an African Patriot
because he was a Pan Africanist.
Um,
he was a devout methodist and very
active in his church and cared about his
church and he was a citizen of the
world.
He was ambassador to the UN for awhile
and he worked very much an international
affairs.
He cared about relations among nations.
Now you might think,
how can you be a loyal Isanti and a
loyal Ghanaian after all the Santa is a
kingdom in the middle of the Republic of
Ghana?
Well,
the answer is,
you know,
look at my father's life as it were.
And look at lots of lives.
People do this sort of thing all the
time.
You can be a loyal citizen of Texas and
a loyal American.
Occasionally they'll pull you in
different directions and then you have a
choice to make,
but much of the time,
you know,
being Texas texts and there's got to be
what matters for some purposes.
And being American is what matters for
others.
And when they do come into conflict,
you have many things to appeal to to
help you resolve the conflict,
including,
I think your own sense of the relative
weight in your own life,
which is up to you of your state
identity as opposed to your national
identity.
So you can't tell people you can't.
These are things that have people have
to figure out for themselves.
Um,
because there is no morally correct,
uncertain though,
ethically pre given answer to the
question,
what's more important,
tax and or American,
um,
uh,
in a Christian or philosopher,
these things are not.
You have to figure it out for yourself.
I think all you can say to people in
trying to be helpful is that
I'm a,
you're often going to have people who
share one of these identities with you,
make demands of you on that basis that
you're entitled to resist in the name of
your more of morality and the,
and the name of a human human identity,
but also in the name of other identities
that you have and what you don't share
with them.
Everybody,
if you just,
um,
I worked at the other day that you
really need to have 32 properties,
uh,
to consider any 32 properties to elect
to have a set of bundles of properties
such as everybody in the world can have
a distinct and unique bundle.
The bundle the properties because two to
the 32 is bigger than 6 billion or 6
billion of us.
Well,
I'm a.
So even in the smallest village,
right?
There are both men and women,
so all the other identities are inflect,
are potentially inflected by gender and
among the women,
some have more resources than others.
Some are married and some are married,
some have children don't have children.
All of these affect how their lives
looked at them and how they get to make
the balance of these things in their
lives and the sort of the key thought of
the liberal tradition.
It goes back to comp,
goes back to Humboldt,
goes back to liberal,
slight mill.
In the 19th century,
the key thought is each human being has
to challenge face the challenge of
making this decision for herself.
You can take advice from other people,
you shouldn't take advice from other
people,
other people can tell you useful things,
but it's your responsibility in the end
to make a decision and you shouldn't
differ that responsibility to anyone
else.